PlayStation TV here to offer one simple  solution to your family's entertainment  needs the playstation TV system is a  sleek compact device with a wealth of  PlayStation Media and family-friendly  hip games like the lego movie video game  Sly Cooper thieves and time and MLB 14  the show the vast library of games from  PlayStation Vita and classics from ps1  and PSP systems means there's something  for everyone for families that already  have a PlayStation 4 at home now they  can stream remote play enabled games  from their ps4 system to the PlayStation  TV when it's time to turn off the games  and settle in for the night there's an  option for that too movies TV shows and  entertainment apps are available to  download from PlayStation Store  PlayStation TV is simple to setup and  the bundle comes with all you need to  join the exciting world of PlayStation  one amazing console one simple way to  bring the family together PlayStation TV  simply amazing  please